J'ai maintenant quelques bons amis aux
États-Unis qui utilisent un fauteuil roulant. Ils
m'ont dit que parfois ils ne peuvent pas
dormir la nuit avant le vol
parce qu'ils sont terrifiés à l'idée que le
fauteuil roulant soit endommagé par les compagnies aériennes
[Musique]
je suis andrea  mchillin d'italien vivant en
allemagne créer une entreprise aux pays-
bas
[musique]
nous vivons plus vite chaque jour et nous nous
déplaçons en jouant en train en partageant la
voiture partageant tout autre type de transport public et
privé l'idée était
vraiment d'essayer de réinventer le
roue pour ouvrir de nouvelles frontières aux
véhicules pliables, ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'une
fois la roue dévoilée en 2018,
j'ai beaucoup retenu l'attention des utilisateurs de sorceleur
, car leur problème est qu'ils
doivent vérifier le fauteuil roulant avant
chaque vol
[Musique]
j'ai lancé la construction du
fauteuil roulant sur linkedin avec l'
image jif où je présentais les roues
pliantes et le dossier et le siège
ensemble
[Musique]
le résultat que des milliers de personnes  le début
des personnes ont repartagé le message puis sont devenus des
millions partout dans le monde entre les
états-unis l'
europe l'asie c'était essentiellement un
boom des médias sociaux
en quelques semaines j'ai eu quelques centaines de
précommandes de fauteuils roulants même si
le sorceleur n'était pas encore sur le marché
c'était  pour moi inattendu car bien sûr
c'était un projet réalisé sur mon
temps privé disons à côté de mon travail
de designer
et maintenant cela devient une réalité
[Musique]
ils doivent enregistrer le fauteuil roulant
avant chaque vol, ce qui signifie que vous
devez être à  l'iport beaucoup plus de temps
avant le vol et la lutte est
que lorsque vous arrivez à
destination, vous avez besoin d'aide, vous avez besoin
de beaucoup d'attention,
il y a des endroits où vous arrivez à
destination et votre fauteuil roulant est en
fait dans une autre ville parce
qu'ils mentent ils  ils le déplacent à un autre
endroit parfois le sorceleur est là mais les
dégâts
sont vraiment une grande lutte qui,
d'une certaine manière, limite également
la façon dont ils peuvent se déplacer librement ou voler, ce
qui signifie t  chapeau, vous devez toujours réfléchir
à trois quatre fois avant de faire un
voyage
après que le magazine Time ait reconnu le revolver
comme l'une des meilleures inventions de 2021, j'ai
reçu 12 000 précommandes d'utilisateurs principalement
également des États-Unis et d'Europe, le
revolver permettra également à l'utilisateur de
stocker  dans le siège passager de la
voiture alors qu'ils conduisent un
véhicule vraiment extrêmement compact, quelque chose qui
était auparavant difficile
, nous voulons donc offrir une nouvelle indépendance
à l'utilisateur
[Musique]
si vous conduisez des voitures extrêmement compactes,
vous pouvez mettre le fauteuil roulant sur le
siège passager super rapidement il
faut presque 10 secondes pour tout plier
[Musique]
la possibilité de collaborer avec l'utilisateur
est la prochaine étape que nous voulons faire
avancer pour créer un produit parfait pour
eux
[Musique]
vous voyez ici il a un
robot  aide pour ouvrir et fermer la
porte ils ont une description des
différents obstacles qu'ils doivent
gravir et passer par-dessus une chaise un slalom
terrain accidenté monter et descendre les escaliers et
ouvrir cl  oser une porte sans les mains
c'est l'équipe de robotique de l'équipe un à nouveau
monter les escaliers avec une vitesse incroyable à
travers ce slalom c'est un super-héros en
suisse juste un peu
l'idée était en fait d'intégrer la
technologie de l'exosquelette avec la roue donc
le fait que l'exosquelette est quelque chose
qui  est bien sûr quelque chose d'innovant
qui sera présenté à l'avenir
pour la production de masse maintenant est bien sûr
quelque chose de vraiment niche, mais avec cette
combinaison de révolution comme roue et d'
exosquelette comme innovation pour apporter aux
personnes paralysées la possibilité de marcher à
nouveau,
nous visons à déconstruire  un
véhicule hybride qui visait à garantir le
meilleur de la technologie exosquelette et
le meilleur de la technologie witcher
ensemble
[Music]
vous